yes,
the new year 2,024 is just around the corner.
we don't know what it will bring,
but of course we hope for the best.
the last few years have given us
met many challenges,
Corona,
Ukraine gets economic crisis and so on.
and we are working on it,
that this yearzwanzigvierundzwanzig
can first influence so far,
becomes economically stable,
that we can save our prosperity,
that we improve internal security.
there are big challenges,
that our country is facing
and we just have very bad
political framework,
partly politically marketed on the Berlin level.
and I am convinced,
We also have to counter Aus Bayern here,
have to put the sensible issues ahead,
have to put us 4 the citizens down,
who work to take care of their family,
take care of the voluntary work,
that make sure that this country runs
and must not allow those who work,
that they deliver,
come under more and more pressure.
in this respect,
this year will be 2,024
of course 1 very challenging year,
but we park at,
we won't let it get us down and we hope,
that the citizens also
faith in politics and those who believe in
not lose in this state,
but get involved,
ClaimVerbesserungsvorschl and for 1
"strong Germany" in 2024.
thank you very much and 1 happy new year!